PROFESSOR: And let me
I assume, for example,
that I'll put the
state alpha beta in.
Alpha and beta.
What do I get out?
So you have this
state, alpha beta.
What do you get out?
Well, state comes in and is
acted by beam splitter 1.
So you must put the
beam splitter, 1 matrix.
And then it comes the mirrors.
And lets assume
mirrors do nothing.
In fact, mirrors--
the two mirrors
would multiply by minus 1,
which will have no effect.
So lets ignore mirrors.
And then you get
to beam splitter 2
and you must multiply by the
matrix of beam squared 2.
And that's the output.
And that output is a
two-component vector.
That gives you the amplitude
up and the amplitude down.
So I should put BS2 here,
BS1 over here, alpha beta.
The numbers move away, 1
over square root of 2 and 1
over square root of 2.
Commute in matrix
multiplication.
Then you multiply
these two matrices.
You get 0, 2, minus
2, and 0, alpha beta.
And you put the 2 in so
you get beta minus alpha.
So here is the rule.
If you have alpha
and beta, you get,
here, beta and minus alpha
here, or a beta minus
alpha photon at the end.
Good.
So let's do our first
kind of experiment.
Our first experiment is to
have the beam splitters here.
D0-- detector D0 and
detector D1 over there.
And let's send in a
photon over here only--
1 or input 0, 1.
Well this photon,
0, 1, splits here.
You act with BS1--
the matrix BS1.
You get two things.
You act with the matrix
BS2, and it gives you this.
But we have the rule already.
If you have an alpha beta,
out comes a beta minus alpha.
So it should have as 1, here,
and minus 0, here, which is 0.
So you get a 1, 0.
So what is really happening?
What's really happening is
that your photon that came in
divided in two,
recombined, and, actually,
there was a very interesting
interference here.
From the top beam
came some amplitude
and gave some reflected
and some transmitted.
From the bottom beam,
there was some transmission
and some reflection.
The transmission from the top
and reflection from the bottom
interfered, to give 0.
And this, too, the reflection
from the top and transmission
from the bottom, were
coherent and added up to 1.
And every single
photon ends up in D0.
If you would put the beam--
well, Mach and
Zehnder were working
in the late 1800s, 1890s.
And they would shine light.
They had no ability
to manipulate photons.
But they could put
those beam splitters
and they could get this
interference effect,
where everything goes to D0.
So far, so good.
Now let me do a slightly
different experiment.
I will now put the same
thing, a BS1 and a beam
going in, mirror,
mirror, BS2 here.
But now, I will put a block
of concrete here on the way.
I'll put it like this.
So that if there
is any photon that
wants to come in this
direction, it will be absorbed.
Photon could still go
like this, but nothing
would go through here.
And here, of course,
there might be D0 and D1.
And here are the
mirrors, M and M.
Now the bottom
mirror is of no use
anymore because there is
a big block of concrete
that will stop any photon
from getting there.
And we are asked,
again, what happens?
What do the detectors see?
And this time, we
still have a 01.
Now I would be tempted
to use this formula,
but this formula was right
under the wrong assumption--
that there was no block here.
So I cannot use that formula.
And certainly, things are
going to be different.
So I have to calculate things.
And we're doing a quantum
mechanical calculation.
Well, up to here,
before it reaches here,
I can you do my
usual calculation.
Certainly, we have BS1
acting on the state, 01,
and this is 1 over square root
of 2, I think, minus 1, 1, 1,
1.
Yup, that B is 1, acting on 01.
And that gives me 1
over square root of 2,
1 over square root of 2.
So, yes, here I have one over
square root of 2 amplitude.
And here I also have 1 over
OK.
Now that's the end
of this amplitude.
It doesn't follow.
But on the other
hand, in this branch,
the mirror doesn't change the
amplitude, doesn't absorb.
So you still have 1 over
square root of 2 here.
And now you're reaching BS2.
Now what is the input for BS2?
The input is a one over
square root 2 in the top beam,
and nothing in the lower beam
because nothing is reaching BS2
from below.
This is blocked.
So yes, there was some
times when something reached
from below, but nothing here.
So to figure out the
amplitudes, here, I
must do BS2 acting on 1 over
the square root of 2, 0.
Because 1 over square
root of 2 is coming in,
but nothing is
coming in from below.
And, therefore, I get 1
over the square root of 2,
1, 1, 1, minus 1, 1 over
square root of 2, 0.
This time, I get 1/2 and 1/2.
OK, we must trust the math.
1/2 here and 1/2 there, so
1/2 a column vector, 1/2, 1/2.
OK, let me maybe tabulate
this result, which
is somewhat strange, really.
So what is strange about
it is the following.
In the first case,
where the interferometer
was totally clear, nothing
in the middle, everything
went to D2.
And nothing went into D1.
But now, you do something that
should block some photons.
You block some photons
in the lower path,
and yet, now you seem to be
able to get something into D1.
There is an amplitude
to get into the D1.
So by blocking a source,
you're getting more somewhere.
It's somewhat counterintuitive.
You will see by the end of
the lecture in 10 minutes,
that it's not just
somewhat counterintuitive,
it's tremendously
counterintuitive.
Let's summarize
the result here--
the outcome in the blocked lower
branch case and the probability
for those events.
So photon at the block--
the photon can end
in three places.
It can end on the block.
It can end on the D0.
Or it can end on D1.
So photon at the block--
well, the amplitude to be here
is one over square root of 2.
The probability should be 1/2.
Photon at D0, probability
amplitude, 1/2, probability,
1/4--
photon at D1, probability, 1/4.
You could put another
table here-- outcome
all open, probability.
And in this case, there's
just photon at D0.
That's 1.
And photon at D1 was 0.